i love you
yeah
now i'm gonna have some fun by myself
i'm feeling so good right now because i
just feel that it was the perfect
episode to go home to if i mean i'm not
glad that i'm home or whatever but it's
just that of all this season this
episode was so important for me and just
living what i lived
in that moment um i'm such a good place
are you ready for this puppy
so for you to be the first colombian
drag artist on a drag race franchise
like what does that mean for you
that is huge the many messages that i
received from uh children and younger
people in colombia it's just incredible
how important representation is
right now and and it has always been
i've never seen someone that i can
relate to on tv and not on a show like
this i have to say my favorite runway of
yours was the marie antoinette inspired
runway
in incredible do you have a personal
favorite of your own i love this look it
is one of my favorites of any of the
drag race franchises i mean that one is
it's
hard to
top it but
i would say my ugliest
[Music]
it was the craziest thing but i i just
felt like
i'm gonna have fun with it and
of course the marian tonight is iconic
and it was so not comfortable but i i
looked so good and i was like okay this
is camp and this i love people think
that i can do this too but showing
people that i can be ugly and laugh
about myself
i felt so good too so yeah those two one
thing i really appreciate about you is
how versatile you can be so now that
you've spent time with all of these drag
artists who do you want to win season
two of canada's drag race like who in
your mind makes the perfect winner at
this point
at this point it's so hard to say that
because everyone has done so good
of course
but i have to say pithia
yes she is the the way that that brain
works it's incredible the creativity
that she has
and the beautiful person that they are
it's just
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos